[Music]
sinewy chrome lakes
elegant cane deceit
rich
birch wood
introducing
the cheska
it's like the right amount of creepy for
this cesca also known as the b32 b64 if
it has arms is kind of having a moment
full disclosure i am literally sitting
on one right now
have been since at least 1999 but this
chair is more than just a throne for
toddler me to practice my penmanship
it's more than a trendy decor item or
popular movie set piece it's a design
icon in the collections of some of the
world's most major museums and
considered among the most important
chairs of the 20th century so where did
this chair come from and why is it
everywhere
[Music]
the cheska chair story begins here
at the bauhaus
the famed german art school slash
commune slash neverending party
genius factory it was founded in 1919 by
this architect walter gropius his goal
was to merge art and industry creating
work that was deeply modern and
simultaneously beautiful functional and
reproducible which was a pretty radical
change from the exclusivity and
ornamental frills of other design
movements
look at these two teapots both from
1920s germany this one is beautiful but
mostly decorative on this bauhaus one
everything is intentional the curved
wooden handle makes pouring easy and
comfortable the slanted spout prevents
drips and it definitely looks sturdy and
industrial except this teapot was
handcrafted out of silver and ebony it
was wildly expensive still is
even though bauhaus designs looked
utilitarian
most of them were basically impossible
to make at scale
that is until our hero marcel breuer mr
cheska chair himself stepped in and
changed everything
broyer was an early student of the
bauhaus and in 1925 he was ruminating on
their whole manufacturing problem when
inspiration struck he looked at his
bicycle's handlebars and realized to
paraphrase bent tubular steel was
bauhaus as heck it's sleek light shiny
strong and this one's a direct quote can
be bent like macaroni first he made this
chair now known as the vasily chair
and then a bunch of other chairs and
tables and stools and this
couch
but for broyer these pieces still
weren't modern enough the ultimate
creation he wrote would be a chair that
floated on an elastic column of air
and in 1928 breuer had another one of
those eureka moments he flipped a stool
on its side and thus the cantilever
chair was
born soon after he debuted the b32
and with it he achieved the purest
manifestation of bauhaus ideals
a chair that showcased the gleaming
modernity of chrome seemed to defy the
laws of gravity and crucially
only required a handful of pre-made
materials to make
soon tonit a company already world
famous for mass-producing bent wooden
chairs was making tons of b-32s and as
other bauhausians designed their own
versions a bunch of other tubular
cantilevered chairs
but it's pretty universally held that
this is the best of them
most cantilever chairs require braces
which both ruins the visual lines of the
chair and makes them rigid and
uncomfortable
breyer's chair doesn't need those thanks
to its structured wooden framing which
holds everything together but still
allows for flexibility and bounce
that added structure also means the
chair can be made from one continuous
length of steel which is bent 16 times
rather than a bunch of different tubes
fused together which makes the chair
lighter and easier to make plus the cane
gives the chair an airy transparency
a feature tonit played up in their 1930s
advertising of which there was a lot
tonet really wanted these designs to
take off the problem was they were
expensive and they seemed a little too
modern for the average home
until
the 60s
a sort of hybrid futuristic look became
all the rage and the b-32 fit in
perfectly gavina the go-to italian
modernist brand began selling it and
they gave it a new name cheska from
francesca broyer's daughter's name
as the mid-century look picked up steam
so did the chesca but unlike those newer
designs the chesca
wasn't copyrighted
so
manufacturers started making completely
legal jessica copies and marketing them
as brewer style chairs
by 1980 the chesca was ubiquitous
one reviewer noted it was as common as
imitated and as mass-produced as a pair
of calvin klein
which at the time was just about the
highest praise there was after that the
chesca never quite went away today there
are many places to buy one and countless
second-hand ones floating around
which only seems to drive up demand its
appeal is only getting broader as both
bauhaus and modernism become popular
again
in short this chair is everywhere
because ever since its inception nearly
a century ago it's been a design marvel
and quite frankly cool as hell
[Music]
you